à l'époque où vous vous êtes mariés
qu'est ce qu'une femme espérait de son
mari c'était quoi pour elle le mari
idéal sotéga y attendait déjà un mkv la
santé et du travail
c'était beau s'ils ne buvaient pas paul
pas demander mieux
bon jeu n'a rien vraiment avec amitié
parce qu'il y avait un moment qu'on se
connaissait
on se mariait avec amitié mais pas avec
amour parce que six ans quand même
puisque vous faisait comme travail
exactement moi j'allais là comme déchets
les os et moi j'ai fait des mines et je
faisais les ménages en plus de vos
travaux chez vous il fallait bien comme
ça un homme ça demande quand même un
grand entretien
est ce que dans le temps vous savez il
fallait beaucoup raccommode y en ai je
te plains mua vous savez fallait
remettre l'école des chenils cols et
poignets des 2 to fail et tout autour
accommoder même moi même on portait
débat avec des semaines madame oui et
vous aviez nom michael mann aucun gros
seins avant parce que les naissances
étaient programmés non ce serait très
bien si j'avais été programmée on ne
connaît pas le temps de chien est ce que
vous avez eu des enfants oui j'en ai
huit
est-ce que vous avez souhaité gens
souhaitaient 3 y avait pas de contrôle
de naissance absolument pas il y avait
absolument rien la seule chose qui était
possible disons que c'est si l'homme
avait daigné prendre des précautions et
ça sert jamais les rencontres et ça non
plus vous avez eu des avortements non
oui oui oui c'était pas tellement
autorisées à l'époque un non paper toys
r on disait sont à beaucoup d'enfants
c'est l'inconvénient c'est que ça coûte
cher est pire qu'une paix à ce moment là
je travaillais
alors on n'avait pas on disait pourvu
qu'on puisse à joindre les deux bouts
j'avais tellement peur de me trouver
enceinte si vous voulez que j'aurais
souhaité ne pas avoir de rapports puis
c'est devenu des rapports sans tendresse
pour moi parce qu'ils me dégoûtait il
sentait le vin il sentait l'alcool mais
il fallait subir sinon c'était toute la
nuit qui faisait des comédiens des
sérénades alors pour que les enfants
puissent être tranquille et pourquoi
autant qu'il faille sbires
j'avais souvent acides et des comédies
pour cette chose là parce que comme
souvent est rentré livres dont ben ils
cherchaient à la chaux-de-fonds majoul
est pas parce qu il avait bu ou alors
ils me frappaient voyez c'était déjà un
motif par exemple nous frapper et
aujourd'hui la marque la ruine c'était
le maître
moi on me disait mon arrivée du zoo
enfin mais mari me disait toi de toute
façon tu n'es qu'une femme tu es toi tu
ne sais pas tu n'as pas le droit à la
parole c'est moi le maître ici c'est moi
qui dois prendre des décisions jamais je
n'avais droit à la parole
vous avez été marié combien de foudras
fois c'était la même chose d'être au
fond les trois fois c'était la même
chose
ma mère était très douce alors ma mère
parce qu'elle était très malheureux
celle avec mon père alors elle me dit
écoute fernande fait comme moi soit
souple ne me gilles ouimet défaut un
moment tu sais mais ai dit ça se passera
tu verras tu verras que ça se passera
il ya en effet je l'écouté puis ça se
passait et vous pouviez pas vous
permettre de tenir tête avant c'était
des discussions remporté l'argent rien
tandis que maintenant les femmes bien
ils sont dix fois mais c'est
généralement pour ça que vous étiez
soumises salé faire ça comment faire
avaler par mois les palestiens de chez
moi je sais pour moi il n'aurait pas
fallu que je me plains de chez mes
parents et marietta des gones me
débrouille toi arrange toi
je m'appelle renard et j'ai 41 ans je
suis né en guyane française et je vis
depuis 24 ans en france
je fais partie du personnel de nuit des
hôpitaux que de votre situation de
famille aux marines merci de batère deux
enfants une fille 17 ans un fils 9 ans
je vise séparés depuis quatre ans et
demi de père de mes enfants le père de
vos enfants
oui père de mes enfants il n'a pas un
nom il s'appelle guy vous n'appelez
jamais par son prénom
pourquoi parce que pour masquer le père
des enfants vous êtes séparés après onze
ans de vie commune
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya eu un
problème particulier dans votre couple
non une fois que mon fils est né j'ai eu
l'impression qu'ils aillent plus besoin
d'homme parce que vous avez besoin d'un
homme avant quand même oui de temps en
temps oui et maintenant vous n'avez plus
besoin de cet argent n'ait plus besoin
mais je pense que qu'avec mon caractère
il vaut mieux que je vis seul qu'est ce
qu'il ya dans votre caractère qui
veulent pas je suis ce que je reproche
aux hommes du match au gem commandes et
je me dirigeais tout chez moi et je
n'aime pas me laisser commander y avoir
l'impression qu'on du sud moyen
quelqu'un qui peut me commander vous
même dans votre éducation rien ne vous
prédisposé à avoir cette autorité
naturelle non ma mère faisait partie des
générations de lobito mari vous êtes
d'une éducation traditionnelle
oui assez strictes catholique bon vous
avez quand même été élevé dans l'idée de
mariage non
oui et pourquoi est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas mariée parce que ce ça n'a jamais
été dans ma ligne de conduite j'ai
toujours été contre les contrats long
terme
votre compagnon qu'est ce que vous lui
reprochez à l'époque de cavaler
et il cavale est pourquoi parce qu'ils
ont ce jeune homme ont le sens de la
cavale dans le sang pour commencer
peut-être parce qu'ils trouvaient pas la
maison ce qui l'aurait ce qu'ils
trouvaient aux doors comment est-ce que
vous traitiez pas très gentiment
c'est à dire en criant souvent ils
faisaient des bêtises
non c'était un homme charmant qui
faisait le ménage qui faisait la cuisine
que j'ai tout ce que je n'aime pas faire
qu'est-ce que vous demandiez de plus
rien
physiquement il vous plaisir oui c'est
un très bel homme il était comment un
mètre 87 et le bilan tire alors que vous
aviez trouvé l'homme idéal e quoi je
vais trouver l'homme idéal je m'en suis
rendu compte que des libertés et depuis
vous avez refait votre vie non ni
parfait ma vie j'ai un copain depuis
deux ans un copain un copain oui plus
jeune que moi avec qui je n'ai pas
l'intention de continuer à vivre
quel âge elle a 29 ans qu'est-ce qui
vous apporte d'autres que votre ex
compagnon
la nouveauté vous avez une relation plus
profonde avec lui qu'avec le premier nom
dans quel sens dans le sens de le
problème d'abord les âges dessus
perpétuellement en train de d'essayer de
le rattraper
jésus perpétuellement en train de me
créer un personnage qui n'est vraiment
pas mon propre personnage surtout c'est
une façon pour vous de rester jeune oui
il m'apporte beaucoup de ce côté il en
est conscient
trop conscient qu'est ce qu'il attend de
vous rien parce qu'il sait pertinemment
qu'un jour ou l'autre ce sera terminé
c'est vous qui bouge qui seraient cédés
ci dessous des idées oui il ya même une
date prévue pour bientôt
vous avez aimé cet homme votre compagnon
mais pourtant vous ne pouvez pas fait
d'efforts pour que ça marche
je pense que ce sont probablement les
enfants qui ont tué notre ville couple
nous habitue à l'époque un studio de 20
mètres carrés ce qui réduisait à néant
votre intimité
quelle était la profession de votre
compagnon et des soudeurs maintenant il
participe à l'éducation de ses enfants
la vie matérielle
oui on verse une pension alimentaire qui
représentent à peu près le neuvième en 2
min pense nous en sortir je travaille
dur en plus je suis parfois à standard
10 et se rend place aux vacances quand
je ne prends pas la poussière de mon
immeuble
vous payez cher votre indépendance voire
oui je paie cher mon indépendance mais
c'est un choix
[Musique]